А ви знаєте шановне товариство і дехто
не шановний у цьому залі коли ти дружиш
з Владою тобі вибачають підкуп поліції
коли ти дружиш з Владою тобі вибачають
ДТП з важкими наслідками коли ти дружиш
з Владою це все окей Куди ти хочеш
тихонечко піти в ліс і сьогодні пан
отрухіна який перший написав донос на
мене і Марусю звіробій за те що ми
казали що на передовій стріляють і на це
треба звертати увагу йому золота
розкажуть що він великий герой бо він не
втік як ще дехто і він великий патріот
був помагав щось тут в Україні коли ми
обговорюємо це питання Та не тільки його
треба позбавляти депутатських
повноважень і не тільки треба позбавляти
терміново депутатських повноважень п'яту
колону яка тут підголосовуємо на
більшості яка зраджувала Україну
тривалий час
сьогодні давайте задамо питання А що А
хто ще не втік і проти кого зараз є
замовні політичні справи генерал
Марченко ви думаєте що Справу проти
нього закрили Ні а він боронить Україну
генерал Павловський Справу проти нього
закрили Ні а він боронить Україну а
бронежилети і катери про які там були
різні інсценуації вони зараз допомагають
нашим воїнам боронити державу Сашко по
грибиський Андрій Антоненко Юлія
Кузьменко Тетяна Чорновол вони всі
воюють за Україну но політичні справи
проти них не закриті бо вони не належать
до владної монобільшості бо вони не п'ю
втікли бо вони боронять державу бо вони
сміють говорити правду так що товариство
будьте чесні самі з собою сьогодні
струхиним і цим беспределом Із
опзжниками ви покриваєте злочини